JN Stones is a world class Rob holding
but celba is a different braet oh my God
you having that don't even ack Rob
holding in the a different St that a lot
of people watch this that's
very the hype trainer around Stones the
last 12 24 months you seen the games in
the Champions League it's not my fault
that their team aren't good enough for
the Champions
League what are you doing here what are
you doing here well we're big dogs
aren't we yeah big BS woof woof you know
what I'm saying barking how are we doing
boys Turkish Big Steve Brothers all good
all good I can see the nerves in your
faces at the moment already you see
nerves in his face
yeah so Steve Turkish Manchester City
Arsenal combined 11 if you guys can't
agree on a position I'm going to be the
judge I'm going to be the decision maker
on this one so hold on lad B brought in
a Chelsea fan to be the judge between
Arsenal and City just remember they've
shown you how to be the real oil Club
yeah well obviously I understand what
it's like to be an oil Club winner and
also know what it's like to be eighth
dropping down the league as well so you
know I've seen both sides yeah you're
actually in in their Shadow oh Club wise
and you're in our shadow London Club
wise I'm not so sure about that we've
got a European that's another debate
that's another debate yeah that's
definitely so we're going to we're going
to do the Wingers together so Steve I'll
let you take it away what what is your
left and right winger pair in here on
the left
side for me Jack
Gish I just think the pressure he came
with the 100 million the first season he
didn't quite cut it you know what I mean
a lot of people give him criticism he
bounced back one a treble and you've got
to look at what he's done in every
competition he's played regular he's not
let the pressure of the first season get
to him he's creating goals assists and
he's won the treble he's won the
European Cup and I just think I mean
going up against Martinelli yeah he's
had a good season but at the end of the
season you've just seen the team f
aren't you charity shield and a dog the
dogs could win I know it should have
been called
average there no we're not doing mascots
we're doing he has actually got a little
plastic dog and at the end putting him
here I like greish but equally listen
greish was under pressure with the 100
million priz tag but Martinelli himself
was under some pressure maybe not in the
lights as it was with greish but he
comes from Brazilian second tier he
comes in lowiy at a time when Arsenal
yeah Arsenal need something you need to
turn the corner somewhere and he watches
sacka get into the side he watches EML
Smith R get into side he had to buy his
time and then finally gets in and he
hits the ground running he doesn't look
back last season he was our top scorer
so for me in terms of our attack he's
probably the most lethal of the three
and he's the one that expect to kick on
and start hitting 20 plus goals a season
I just think Jack Gish can get in
Arsenal's team on the left I don't think
so but Martinelli hasn't got
the discipline all the brain to playing
pep guardo's team I
think this looks like it's up to you
because I think I think Martin Le goes
into Man City and Pro in the pudding Pro
in the pudding it looks like it's up to
me even though you made a stronger
argument in my opinion but I do feel
like Martin going 6 million versus 100
million Steve in terms of value for
money as well I don't feel like greish
has has delivered we can't be basing on
price tags why don't we base it on
trophies then do because a trophy is a
team the price teag is the individual
unfortunately
I'm going to give that but you know what
Steve Steve was very convinc to the
Arenal cuz there was more argument here
than there is here that's for sure he
not even thought about that let's put a
nice red chip there here you go mate
thank you very much nice doing business
with you do you want to give me another
red one cuz we're going to go to the
right hand side I've got a cab to catch
so I think this one needs to be done
real quick is this definitively Steve
sacka comes in and starts saaka versus
foden
foden don't do it the two star boys
England Internationals I know he's come
up through the Academy I know he's the
Manchester City Star boy but sack's
sacka stepped up in the last two years
both Club level and international level
look Fen this season he looks he looks
good looker Fon last season sack was
better Jose he was England would tell
you that who starts for England SC of
South going that we ain't going after
that who was England's best player at
the World Cup and eurs last couple yeah
because the thing is with Phil folden
nobody knows where to play him that's a
problem that nobody knows where to
problem for Phil folden is in this team
so without a shadow doubt he's in it but
does he have to be in it in that
position in this team no well well this
is what I'm going to say we might have
to come to a compromise we might have
listen sack is a great player I like him
love watching him think he's fantastic
my argument would be Phil folder on that
side but do you know what I'm a fair man
I'd have be sacker at man city right
wing two up blow whistle load a whistle
let's full time I think there's a
comeback on the car I would have I would
have also agreed with that purely
because he starts week in week out he
doesn't have much competition he is
under a lot of pressure as Arsenal star
boy to deliver constantly on that right
hand side and I think foden is a player
that for me is ridiculously gifted I
can't separate the two on talent I
really can't I think foden's ridiculous
high seing but he does need to be in
that team consistently have that same
responsibility I think you're going to
see that and that's difficult under pep
because he always were don't forget
Phil's been doing it for a long time and
I think you're seeing the best of f fer
now the Midfield we're going to get on
to next the Midfield three we're going
to do it all together that we don't even
need to talk about that rodri
unbelievable best defensive midfielder
in the world on and off the field he a
Class Act you know what I mean he's not
there's nothing um no hairs and Grace's
problems with him he just gets and he's
so big and you're starting to see it now
he's dominating games on his own in
there the the the these teams that play
that double and he's he's he's in there
fighting with him on his own you know
what I mean but he's he's now adding
goals yeah he's he he's adding assists
he's he's all over the park and you know
no he's he he WS the European Cup yeah
mean the goal the the Champions League
winning go that's what I'm saying I'm
going to be Shameless here well he's
suspended for the next game we have
coming up he yes can we can we not
include him in this
debate now rri is R's in there he's the
closest thing to busc since buset I
think this is an easy one we all knew
where this blue chip let's let's not lie
to ourselves mention City making some
sort of comeback here it's about time
Trel Winn has got in in this in it I
mean thank you we had to make you sweat
bro you know what I mean we had to make
sure that it was a difficult difficult
start let's go to these these number
eights these Midfield positions because
there're some talented players in buying
for these spots Kevin De BR there de BR
is the first person we have to talk
about yeah he's unbelievable in he
forget forget Man City Arsenal combin 11
debron could make a premier league era
combined 11 that's he he's been
outstanding and you know when we signed
in the 60 million rejects they put on
the papers and that but ever since the
first day he's come it's just it's just
unbelievable Kevin Kevin De Bren gets in
anyone's team he's clutch on top of
everything that Steve said which I agree
with he's clutch when Man City need him
he he he he steps up he isn't as tall as
HZ and he hasn't got the
F again as a Chelsea uh fan I can safely
say you're wrong I thought you might be
on my side there we might get another
red one in there but all jokes aside the
Bri to be honest the least the least
argument on this 11 is probably de Bry
for me I'm just worried about what Steve
has in mind next to De Bry here because
of a conversation earlier about a
certain Englishman but we we'll see I'll
give you debin of course Super
C we got one slot left now has to be I
know who you're going to say has to be
red but how odard usually plays in the
right off space there you go oh so we're
going to okay you're going to you're
going to cuz that would have made his
argument very difficult I must say cuz
very fluid these days you don't just
turn up have one good season all of a
sudden you're in the team against
players that have had four or five Good
Seasons you know what I mean but who who
who are we talking about Fen four or
five good what fen's had how many
seasons no he hasn't had a season like
older God did last year he can't you
ever heard that saying one season wonder
I don't think that already this season
he started well older God has he yeah
really yeah better than
folden no yeah no no no no no no he's
not he's not not at all imagine all
theard in the Manchester City's running
games and we're
undefeated you're drawing to full them
at home and just drop points to
Tottenham yeah but your team's better
overall that's that's where but if older
guards the man he needs to be grabbing
these games by the Scruff of the neck
Phil Fen grabbing the game the other day
older guard's more a conductor than
someone that's going to grab the game by
the scuffling it e even older guard's
pressing is it's no no one presses like
alard in the Premier League he's captain
no one he's Captain he's the one that's
he's the one that's Captain the Aral to
turn it around the corner from eighth
place finishes Bernardo Silva can in
there instead of I like Bernardo Silva a
lot I do like Bernardo Silva a lot
Bernardo I was going to put I could have
argued bernardo's point on the right but
I like sacka and I thought you know what
and I like folden I could say if you
want if you want to drop Fen we'll go
Bernardo but you lose you lose both I
think Bernardo is a bigger argument to
older guard than folden is that's for
sure but I'd still go Old Guard no
Bernardo Silva and your and your mate
here needs him he needs that you know
that Norwegian he he no he don't I like
the way he tried to that communication
he don't knock about with them
Norwegians anymore he's a man he wants
his manchest International break they go
away together they catch the same flight
it could it could help I just think no I
don't I can't see it one season one
season for odard does not get him in
against a Phil folden and B Bernardo Sil
in that season he matched the bruyne's
Premier League record of goals in one
season from a midfielder older God
matched that in that one season so it's
not a one it's not a one season wonder
when you're leveling up that much as
well as being Captain as well as leading
the team's press more often than not
because he does lead the Press people
tend to think it's jayus or when jayus
was out for months last year our press
was still Immaculate at times and and
older guard is the leader of that press
he's so vocal he's so young I like
Bernardo Silva and if we're talking
quality for Quality there's a much
closer argument but I think older guard
wins it because of the leadership traits
and the the accountability he takes it's
very hard not to look at trophies and
games that you've won in because they've
delivered in the big big games my
argument to oard is where was odard at
the business end of the season there was
no excuse for Arsenal you were 10 points
ahead at one point the ball was in your
court and when it got tough these
players these players the ones you want
to get in these they W missing and the
captain my players but my players these
they stepped it up you know it's right
you know it's rightel Chelsea can sign
one of Sila you've got um mentality you
can play right left Center and he's not
going to let you
I would get Bernard swear you pick
Bernard he would he's unbelievable play
Sensational Steve I have to give you
this one Bernardo sil's been doing it
for years and he's a top player some of
the Champions League performances not
making three people one person three
times in a row I mean he's just you know
have you seen how many man older guys
nmed over the last year and a half bro
you don't win anything for nutmegs that
Midfield free there wins the Premier
League for you if that's in Arsenal's
team you're lifting trophies and you're
not just stroking dogs at the end of the
season okay guys gra midf again he's
took the lead he's took the lead he's
he's nak there we are going to go to the
he's there no no no no no he's nak there
do you know do you know what I want the
whole four done together you know why
because he's going to try to put center
backs at fullback no it depends right no
let's start left back okay who you
putting at left back
tchenko may won titles for you know why
did we get rid of him it was his time it
was his time I was our time to get rid
did zenko not play Key Parts in City
title wins of course he did yeah of
course he did but when I look at the
system when I look at the system now if
I'm looking at getting a player in now I
wouldn't have zinchenko back in that
team over nanak in no way no City fan
now who's seen them both would choose
zinchenko over AK and I just think if
you want a safe steady left back who's
going to give the ball early to your
Winger he's the man I think zinchenko
hampers Martinelli sometimes but if you
want a left back that can Aid the attack
if you want a back that's a passer of
the ball and someone that can get into
the half spaces then zinchenko all over
a in that department I think for this
debate this left back decision that I'm
going to make is very dependent on who
plays at right back because if you're
going to play an attack-minded right
back then I would go with vanak if
you're going to play a defensive minded
right back and you're going to shift it
to a three then I have no problem
playing zinenko because you've got
balance and you've got rodri so all
right let's do right back let's just
let's let's do the fullbacks together
because if you've gone with a you've
gone with
senchenko who the right back I want to
know the right back before I before I
decide before I say my decision on the
right back Kyle Walker is one of the
greatest right backs in Premier League
era but we're basing this off recent
form last year or so L say and Ben White
was the or the second best right back
last season in the Prem it's only him
it's him and trippier Steve Kyle Walker
started about 10 games last season you
cannot say k k Walker played well last
season he started about 10
a a lot out here wasn'ta he played well
though he played well look at him this
season he started every game yeah he
started well but Ben White is also you
know no K Walker though he's he's not
but now right now Ben White is a better
right back than KY Walker no he's not he
not happing no chance Cal Walker no it's
no way I know he's a listen you know
what's difficult here and I I understand
Steve because it's like it's like having
me sit here after Arsenal win a treble
and all my players have been a part of
it and telling me to take out someone
for someone else that's imine me trying
to Sho hor a Kian if they won the treble
no but reality is Ben White last season
he had another one the best or second
best good season FC yeah they all had a
good season yeah but look at if I talk
about Seasons look at our season one the
treble but K Walker didn't play a
massive part in that trouble it was AI a
lot of the time he did play a massive
part in it that's where Real Madrid he
played against Venus year but right yeah
that game but he did because he he's a
leader he's captain on off the pitch you
the documentary City just brought out
you watch him in the dressing room he's
going round doing a mentality again is
key the running is key Kyle Walker came
in and yeah pep changed the system but
he's realized how important Kyle Walker
is now he plays week in week out in
isolated situations Walker shows his
quality shows his level because he's one
of the greatest but consistency over the
last 12 months Steve that has to count
and Ben White has been very consistent
and the thing is Ben White is the
perfect right back for Pep he's got the
build and he can step into a he can step
into Midfield man no is he peps a
football man this is the option Ben
White and e or zenchenko and Walker
that's how I see
it I
just us in your DMs mate which one of
them is in your DMs let's make a
decision okay I'll is anybody willing to
sacrifice cuz I don't believe I don't
believe any team deserves to have both
fullbacks if I'm completely honest I
really don't Ben White
AK no I go the white was very good last
I go the other way you go the other way
so you're going walk and then you can
decide that's a good that's a good mixup
I'm going to go Ben White because I
think he was more important to Arsenal
last season on that right hand side than
K Walker was to Manchester City I know
KY Walker had some big games and he's a
legend and he's a legend don't get me
wrong but I think Ben White is very V if
you're watching some I try kwalker is
probably the greatest right back of all
time in the and you're leaving him out I
am but this is based on this is based on
what happened Cent we'll come back for
the in this was an all time if this was
K Walker if you're listening if this was
an all time you'd be in the team but
last season Ben White was basically
playing every game and for that reason I
will give you AK because I do think AK
was one of the best defenders in the
League last year um very important to
Manchester City he was and he was
unbelievable never let us down he did
not not once let's get to these center
backs de Diaz Stones no way 100% Diaz CA
no chance to leave out Stones diaza what
Stones he starts about 15
you mad what Stones he starts about 15
playing defensive Midfield last he had
the best season he's ever had he
inverted very well towards the end of
the season he play season J Stones has
been insane last season insane it was a
myth I watched it with me St was City's
best defender right yeah cuz Diaz was
injured so if anything Diaz came back
and and everything clicked into gear but
he it was unbelievable said best
defender no highlight from last season
came when he kept on doing that that's
not defending this is defending here no
you a't all the blocks all the all the
when when we didn't have Diaz at the
back Stones was the man holding it
together when Diaz came back and we had
to change the system that just shows you
how good Jon Stones is yeah if you'd
have changed your system at the end of
the season you might have won the league
you didn't have the players to do it ca
cannot do what Stones does Stones can do
what CBA does Jon Stones is Jon Stones
is a world class Rob holding but celba
is a different oh my God you having that
don't even different holding in
the stone a lot of people watch this
disrespectful Stones you not going to
make me disrespect I like stones but
Stones The Hype train around Stones the
last 12 24 months you've seen the games
in the Champions League it's not my
fault that their team aren't good enough
for the Champion League the only go spor
in Lisbon yeah and people like that were
coming there and running rings around
them Man City came there ran rings
around them they didn't do nothing Jon
stones in against Real Madrid bnab about
thingy Bayern Munich Champions League
final Johnny Stones Johnny Johnny Stones
you've heard the tun
Steve if CA played instead of stones you
win
theal botles no chance he bottles it he
bottles it I tell you what Steve
everything Todd Bley who do you want him
to call tomorrow for or man no cuz
Stones is getting older so that's a bad
argument but what I'm saying is this is
about winning this is about winning
isn't it seen a picture of your team at
the end of the season with a dog and a
charity sh aring about the dog Sean
Stones has got the treble and the
freedom of Manchester and he wears a
kagul listen I don't even know what AO
is John Stones Ruben Diaz is there so
you agree with Diaz I agree with Diaz
okay let's give let's give Steve the
first chip on that left side of Defense
I agree di Diaz is in Diaz said Jon
Stones all
day now on that second position CBA CBA
all day you know what I'm going to let
you decide that I'm going to let you
decide that but you you listen it's a
long walk
home yeah it's a long walk home matis
you're you're you're a foot man you're a
football man always man culture if you
say the wrong thing then I don't even
know if I can continue this show CBA is
unbelievable don't get me wrong and he's
going to have a big career but right now
based on what Stones has done in his
career and what he did last season I
have to give it to Stones he's the
better player right now right now he's P
pep would swap them and pay money on top
this is for you John this is for
you see what he's doing civa I got to
work with people so can go away so let's
get to the most controversial
positions go for it Striker we'll start
there yeah Big Earl in it you know
listen he don't I don't think he he gets
enough credit there's people there was
people in the media saying he chose the
wrong Club you know he's oh he's not
he's not that good he's a tapping
Merchant 52 goals in all competitions 22
year old you look at his progression the
way he's come from all the different
clubs the way his dad and his agent have
managed him and that and he's just he
was a joy to watch last season he was
unbelievable this is Testament to how
good Harland is because I think jayus
and deserve honorable mention because
behind har if we're talking about
Strikers in the league we're talking
about those two in and amongst the
conversation and because it's dealing
with ER Harem there's no there's no
competition he will be the best Striker
for the next 10 years Bo is Harlem let's
be honest was never going to go any
other way broke all the records
unbelievable in the Champions League
unbelievable in the Premier League and
uh still scoring still going still going
goalkeeper next yes's it's
ramsdale doesn't start right now for no
listen you this Edison Edison a lot of
goalkeepers model the game on Edison's
play now you know what I mean playing
out from the back I think with these two
him here he's important with him here
dropping and like you say when people
were pressing us Edison's dink over the
top bringing these into play ramale is a
good goalkeeper I think he's he he he's
I don't it's unfortunate what's happened
there whether he's got a bit too big for
his boots and they brought someone else
in that that might R he made some great
saage with day scene yeah but Edison so
underrated you know um modern day
goalkeeper passing both feet left right
cool not the best shot stopper in the
world free Golden Gloves Champions
League Edison yeah yeah this is nearly
as easy as a striker argument why
because listen Remo is a good keeper and
he's helped turn us around over the last
couple he's been a big part of that Ry
as well getting at the back distribution
wise quality but even if you ask Aaron
you know Keepers he'd look up to in in
in football now I'd assume Edison would
be there Edison is one of the you know
benchmarks for a ball playing goalkeeper
now so goes without saying I think
ramell deserves a shout because he's
been good for us but Edison's clear
there you are Edison in goal this CA
one's really annoyed me but it's a great
team well boys it's be an absolute
pleasure Big Steve thank you so much
good to see you pleasure Turkish brother
pleasure we done all right Steve Sunday
see you big game big game I don't really
wish anyone like any luck as a Chelsea
fan oh we might need some of that thank
you for not cooking me I appreciate
today made the best team win and I hope
you don't get
[Music]
relegated Smith row no where do you mean
where where's he going to play could
play uh even at number 10 position play
out wide he said to who who you got
there we got folden greish mahrez play
in front of greish no he play in front
of greish smth bro is a better player
than greish